on vous a fait un petit récapitulatif de
toutes ces stars décédées sur qui on a
appris des choses et père sombre et on
en discute juste après vraiment là c'est
une transition parfaite mais c'est vrai
qu'on apprend des trucs de ouf et vous à
nous dire ce qui est possible de faire
ou pas regarde depuis toujours on
apprend tôt ou tard que nos stars
préférées ont également des phases plus
sombre et bien souvent c'est
lorsqu'elles sont décédés que ces
phrases que ressurgissent exemple avec
edith piaf
après sa mort on a appris qu'elle était
une véritable croqueuse d'hommes ou
encore claude françois il ya quelques
mois un reportage nous révéler qu'il
aurait en réalité une fille cachée
j'ai découvert qu'ils étaient mes
parents de naissance et notamment mon
père naturel claude françoise et les
stars internationales ne sont pas en
reste exemple avec ce proche du chanteur
george michael décédé en 2017 qui a
révélé qu'il était complètement accro à
la drogue
[Musique]
récemment on apprenait également de
nouvelles révélations sur l'animateur
star jean luc delarue il accélère tout
le monde crie dans l'habitacle la
voiture finit par se fracasser contre un
poteau de la bretelle de sortie avant de
faire trois tonneaux ou encore sur la
chanteuse amy winehouse
un instant que vous regarderez
alors que ces stars sont très appréciés
avec deux grandes communautés a voulu
vraiment envie de découvrir ça alors on
va retenir sur jolly deux petites
journées avec mathieu altermatt vous
qu'est-ce que vous révéler sur johnny
qu'on ne savait pas avant par exemple
parce que je trouve drôle c'est que je
révèle ses deux demi frères en fait ils
avaient deux demi frères qui avait dix
ans - que lui n'en parlait jamais c'est
vrai que du côté de sa mère
et ce qui est drôle c'est la profession
des demi-frères inspecteur des impôts
non oui vraiment il y voit l'effet des
tours de vis frère de gianni meersman et
il les a fait savoir sa vie je les adore
je pense à maintenant et je les adore
quand même on a toujours des relations
vous avez le loup n'est pas moi je les
aime beaucoup oui on reste sur johnny la
société on y apprend des choses sur
johnny et moi j'en ai marre de ces cinq
jeunes
taisez vous c'est ça qui nous donne des
leçons de vertu et ce qu'on a appris sur
johnny mais par exemple l'histoire des
demi frères qui sera la nôtre qui est
terrible explique beaucoup et je sais de
40 de johnny hallyday j'ai jamais allé
voir son fils david en concert mais
jamais ce qui explique beaucoup de
choses sur le ressenti aujourd'hui de
david est le problème qui n'est jamais
allé le voir en vrai ce n'est pas par
méchanceté pas johnny tu es quelqu'un
qui vivait sur rodolphe la dette était
un peu lâche il faut lui dire je
l'esprit mais il n'y a pas de méchanceté
c'est juste que voilà les pourquoi
pourquoi il n'a jamais été mon avis de
penser que ce soit parce qu'il est sur
nos plages
il a cessé il a eu envie de peut-être
une forme de rivalité peut-être david a
toujours été beaucoup plus proche de sa
mère que de son père de façon la vie
c'est vraiment le fils de sa mère le
valais est ce que vous confirmez bernard
mottais ce que vous connaissez bien oui
il a raison le seul truc bête alors vous
parliez de catherine deneuve
d'après mes sources à moi il ya eu crac
crac comme johnny catherine à tel point
qu'il a tenté de se suicider au volant
de sa triumph dans l'autoroute de
l'ouest
et alors c'est ce qu'il a fait il a
bloqué le conducteur foyer il parle il
parlait beaucoup il disait plein de
choses ils avaient bloqué le compteur de
sa bagnole je passe tout court de mettre
au courant bien sûr et puis au milieu
donc est ce qu'on peut il était fou de
l'amour de catherine deneuve mais leur
relation n'est pas posée ils ont tourné
les parisiennes
elle avait 19 ans lui 18 un truc comme
ça bref fou d'amour mais elle a envoyé
balader très vite après crac crac quand
même un moment j'en parle dans mon livre
zikara cracra alors alors reprend le lis
tu vas leur dette
les quatre effets pack d'élues et il m'a
raconté quand même c'est johnny qui t'a
raconté oui et pas le crâne de 2,9
il me dit qu'il était fou d'amour pour
elle maintenant pas l'amour faire
consommer je pense à tu crois tu aussi
bon alors lui ces îles et dans tous les
six mois
alors entre il prend l'autoroute de
l'ouest avec sa triumph déçu en pleurs
etc
ils bloquent le compteur de sa bagnole
de sport pour mourir pour mourir il faut
aussi font ce manque de pot et ça c'est
du johnny 5% mais panne d'essence ya
plus d'efforts way est irréaliste en
attenant qui n'a pas pu se tuer je veux
dire c'est vrai il me l'a racontée par
lhenry c'est vrai ça incroyable c'est
fou cette histoire j'ai voulu faire là
trop la même chose en trottinette pour
bétail journée foncé contre 1 bat à
couscous
non mais oui mathieu qui m'agace et la
preuve quand même que tout ça c'est
n'importe quoi c'est qu'on a des grands
biographie si on à bernard iv est bien
connu johnny est un grand biographe qu'à
travailler aucun des deux n'a la vérité
ne qu'il y ait couché pas couché de thé
sur moi je n'ai pas d'info moins jeunes
vous avez chacun écrit des mairies n'ont
même pas un des deux alors qu'une sur
deux ce qui apparemment a apparemment
allez les mecs ça voilà la preuve que
non mais pourquoi ça sent pas bon
c'est essentiel est ce qu'ils ont touché
les açores par an alors on va on va on
va revenir à tu pourquoi vous écrivez un
livre sur johnny voilà quelques toqué
après savoir ce que c'est parce que vous
aviez peur des procès ah non pas du tout
non non pas du tout moi que cg de foyer
en maison dix pendant dix ans et johnny
est un des premiers artistes et qui j'ai
travaillé j'avais 22 ans à l'époque a
découvert à un type qui était
étonnamment très sympathique pas du tout
comme on l'imaginait pas étonnamment oui
parce que les gens s'imaginent à un type
avec bigard encore avant la ronde le
tribunal président et moi je vois johnny
je les rencontrais une fois mais avant
de le rencontrer
j'étais fan de lui je les rencontre et
j'étais encore plus fan de lui mais
j'étais sûr que c'est un mec très simple
d'accès sans grande star sont des
diamants avec des facettes multiples il
suffit qu'un jour on tombe sur la
facette qui est pas bonne nous avez une
mauvaise idée sur en fait certes il
montre édition n'est tombé que sont les
moyens
les biographes ont un rôle essentiel
pour l'histoire moi je trouve que
d'ailleurs même l'histoire de france
c'était son avocat non non mais mais si
tout est comparable
marie antoinette avait un avocat qui
s'appelait à ce moment-là chauveau
lagarde
c'est lui qui était dans l' il était
dans la classe d'isabelle livre sur
marie antoinette parce qu'on l'accusé
d'un c'est ça les potes avec ses enfants
avec son fils il faut la trouve que
c'est bien voilà eh bien il a révélé ils
enfin blanchi parce que les biographes
réparé parfois l'excès justice sur les
carrières alors tu viens sur évidemment
johnny on écrit ça bien sûr à voir on
écrit plein de trucs sur johnny
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore le temps
franchement qu'est ce qui vous reste à
savoir il ya cinq livres qui me désole
c'est que ça fait maintenant plus de 20
ans que de nous parler plus fort on ne
parle on est pas que mon micro avec
whatever comme ça oui donc on ne parle
que de choses qui n'ont pas de rapport
avec ce qu'il a fait on papa de sa
carrière on parle alors je vous dis les
choses dans certains cas amy winehouse
elle avait un personnage d'une rockeuse
on savait qu'elle avait une vie dissolue
on raconte des choses ça ne change rien
sur johnny a déjà tout dit survivre il a
fait les interviews qu'il avait fuit
fait ça il y avait deux demi frères ou à
l'armée
cinéma mais même à l'arrière
aussi dernièrement voilà sûr que
françois que françois lui aussi grands
mythes de la chanson française
lui aussi a fait face à un grand
scandale après sa mort il aurait en
réalité une fille cachée on a vu ça et
elle a parlé l'an dernier pour la
première fois dans un documentaire de
paris première ça aussi c'est sorti
après voilà vous vous avez bien connu
que je connaissais depuis vingt ans -
l'affiché des génies d'avec là mère il
ya plus de vingt ans des jaurès à les
lire à mort dans le pays n'était pas
prêt pour mais lorsque vous disiez sont
les livres cyril mesbah dit il veut que
les livres soient rendre justice et soit
vrai parce que ça sert de base avant
marquant le coup j'ai regretté d'avoir
soutenu nos jours le livre sur jean luc
delarue parce que je n'ai lu
attentivement depuis il est bourré
d'erreurs et de contrevérités warmez
mouraient mouraient des régimes et ça ça
m'énerve qu'elle dit parce que
franchement si elle en a parlé en disant
du bien sans l'avoir croyez que c'est un
gars de m6 qui l'avait compris
[Applaudissements]
ces déchets jouer le match commence les
téléspectateurs est ce que il fallait
révélé cet amour secret de johnny
hallyday qu'est ce que vous dites oui ou
non
oui à travers son nom à 63% croyez moi
la cij et 37% des français qui achètent
le livre moi j'suis content alors allez
alors on arrête on arrête là dessus